also nur noch mal damit ihr kurz
Bescheid wisst ich habe früher mal auf
meinem Youtube Kanal habe ich auch auf
die Zimmer reagiert es ist so schön das
ist für mich ein unnormal krank genau
wir haben auf jeden Fall schon mal auf
die Zimmer reagiert und das werden wir
jetzt heute wieder tun let's go Zimmer
Nummer 1 was äh ich jetzt hier gerade
mal geöffnet habe von der User namens
Avocado was halten wir davon wir machen
Skala 1 bis 10 was ich sehr sehr Cosi
finde ist dass sie hier so ein Sessel
drinne ich schwöre euch da wird sie
niemals drin sitzen sondern immer nur
auf dem Bett liegen oder irgendwie so
aber ist auf jeden Fall sehr sehr cool
dass sie einen hat Laser Luca ah zehn
von zehn auch sehr süße Avocado oder
irgendwie so oder made nächstes Zimmer
meine Damen und Herren auf jeden Fall
ein kompletter
Kontrast zum Zimmer gerade ansonsten hat
aber auch einen Stream Deck hier am
Start das heißt der Stream vielleicht
auch oh er hat auch noch mehr Bilder
geschickt hat das hier finde ich ja echt
nicht schön ihr mögt die Lichter boah
nee ich ich finde die hat jeder und die
Wissen erinnern
sogar so Laser Luca fake-kissen hier
waren
okay er hat auch noch ein drittes Bild
tatsächlich geschickt von seinem Zimmer
das sieht so aus
chillig Bro menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßen oh hier kommen wir zum Zimmer
ihr wisst wie ich zu sowas stehen
Qualität ist
bescheiden ich meine ich finde sie schön
aus auf so Bildern aber ich würde da
wirklich ich würde Augen und
Kopfschmerzen kriegen wenn die LEDs
nicht da wären finde ich sehr sehr cool
weil ich finde Dachschrägen auch immer
sehr gemütlich in dem Zimmer sehr viele
Preise auf jeden Fall auch gewonnen
davon kann Zander nur träumen einzige
was sie von diesem ganzen Krams hier hat
ist die Ablage die auch noch schief
hängt eine Uhr hat es auch nicht sie
kann ja die Uhr nicht lesen wie viel Uhr
ist das jetzt hier ich weiß dass ein
Zeiger auf 9 ist und ein Zeiger auf drei
wie viel Uhr ist es
nee
das ist tatsächlich viertel vor drei
das stelle ich mir richtig richtig cool
vor wenn du einfach deine Leiter oben
hast so hast du dein normales Zimmer und
eine schlafen willst glaubst du die
Leiter runter gehst hoch und kannst von
oben die Leiter wieder hochklappen hast
dann richtig Cosi und abgeschlossen oben
wenn dann irgendeinen Einbrecher kommt
checkt er ja gar nicht dass du hier oben
bist also so würde ich als Kind immer
denken der hat noch ein Bild von der
anderen Seite geschickt sich gerade oh
wow LED overload ich bin überhaupt kein
Fan von diesen ganzen LEDs ihr wisst wie
es läuft aber wenn Sie das auf so ein
ganz warmes leichtes Licht umschalten
kann
das wäre will dass hier oben ist
wahrscheinlich so ein Tageslichtlampe
ich würde sagen acht von zehn weil ich
finde lichttechnisch Licht ist das
allerwichtigste wenn du einen Raum
erfüllen möchtest Pack da nicht alles
mögliche an Materialien rein schönes
Licht ist das Allerbeste was es gibt der
gefragt hat viele schreiben jetzt zehn
also für euch bisher der Favorit oder
wie wird jemand seine ganze Wohnung
geschickt und Katzenbaum nee Null von
zehn ey überhaupt kein Front aber das
ist es für mich auf jeden Fall nicht
klar es ist Geschmackssache jeder muss
sich einfach damit gemütlich fühlen und
damit wohlfühlt alles an Gemütlichkeit
finde ich das sieht aus wie so ein Flur
das ist so ein Durchlauf
irgendwie ganz viele Bilder an der Wand
wahrscheinlich zu Familien wo wie gesagt
überhaupt keinen frontness es ist nur
Geschmackssache aber meins ist auf jeden
Fall nicht mal Katzen gar nicht so
zerkratzt am Rücken machen wir weiter
mit dem Setup Katze Null von zehn aber
das ist sehr sehr geil hier oben finde
ich mit diesen ganzen Sachen auf checkt
dir voll und so viel die Farben passen
auch null bei der Wohnung ja es ist
immer Geschmackssache wenn Leute das
schön finden ist ja ist ja alles gut
habe Management ist auf jeden Fall das
ist auf jeden Fall top am Start hier
Stuhl ist lost
einfach nur bis auf die Heizung ja ich
dachte mir zu Beginn als schon gesehen
habt dachte ich mir so okay können
vielleicht ganz cool sein aber jetzt
nicht noch grüne Wand aber dann so ein
piss grüner Vorhang das Grün passt gar
nicht dazu blaues Licht Sonnenstuhl
hölzernfarbener Tisch und dann schwarz
Regal passt irgendwie alles nicht so
ganz habt ihr recht oh das ist
wahrscheinlich ein Mädels oh nee was ist
das denn Jungs würden mir auf die Idee
kommen ja hier noch so eine Couch oder
zweite Katze hier noch ein Panorama Bild
ne das ist eine Wand das ist eine Wand
das ist eine Wand und das jetzt eine
Wand es wirkt sehr sehr groß ist glaube
ich aber sehr sehr klein und sehr gut
was aus dem Platz gemacht wird hier
dieses Bett mit einem Raumteiler mit so
einem kleinen Raumteiler zu der Sitzecke
und hat damit ganz klar getrennt okay
hier ist mein privater Bereich und hier
sind Freunde da so finde ich sehr sehr
schön vor allem die Beleuchtung hier
unten so eine kleine Lampe in der Ecke
und so oh nein
wenn Sie hier die Leselampe hat liegt
sie hier mit dem Kopf ey das geht gar
nicht nehmt mal bitte kurz an der
Umfrage teil wohin schaut ihr beim
schlafen wenn nicht Tür ist ist ein
Psycho ohne reden sagt Julia das ist
auch meine Ansicht hier 60% haben gesagt
äh 60% haben gesagt sie schauen zur Tür
geschickt
auch noch geschickt
[Musik]
das Auto wieder der klassische Stuhl ne
ich weiß nicht ist irgendwie zu benutzt
für ein Schrank aber zu sauber für die
Wäsche kommt aber auf dem Stuhl es ist
auf jeden Fall sehr ehrlich das kann man
auf jeden Fall sagen auch hier wieder
der der also das hier die Tür ist jemand
könnte die Tür aufmachen du siehst die
Tür geht auch aber du weißt nicht wer
dort steht ich hätte immer noch das
Verlangen direkt aufstehen und Rum
gucken wenn er dann ist und das dann
Phase ist irgendwie dass er das hier
haben wir drinnen den Top 3 und wir
haben das hier in den Top 3 Johanna
schreibt warte kurz zehn Minuten ich
räume gerade für dich auf
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt mal ganz oben am 9.3 schon
geschickt also das ist wirklich zwei
Wochen her hier guck mal als ich auch
noch den Ikea gut auf ich finde es ist
ein Touch Laptop drauf Bildschirm drauf
dann hier grünes LED hier hinten also
logischerweise sieht man ja irgendwie
rot gelb hier ist noch mal die andere
Ecke
ein Schlagzeug warum heißt es Schlagzeug
Schlagzeug man schlägt
warum heißt das nicht Trommelschlag oder
irgendwie sinnvoller klar mein Kind und
glücklich sein soll machen was möchte
aber wenn es mit Schlagzeug anfängt
würde ich ausziehen du weißt wenn ein
Kind aus der Schule kommt oh jetzt
geht's los
ich finde auch es kann sich nicht gut
anhören ich kann richtig gut zufällig
ich mache jetzt mal Doggy
viermal nein alles voll hier auch an der
Tür ey diese direkt von zehn schreibt
und wer Null von zehn schreibt ja finde
ich auch ein bisschen zu viel aber viele
Mädels waren ja so oder vielleicht auch
ein Junge keine Ahnung das Verstehen
nicht wieso sammelt man Monster Energy
Dosen gibt die doch lieber ab dann hast
du ein bisschen Geld gerade wenn man ein
bisschen jünger ist kann man das so echt
gut gebrauchen der hat immer oder er hat
mir noch andere Bilder geschickt und
zwar das hier oh lol
einfach Minecraft mit Luca Poster an der
Wand mein Buch mein Smiley no way ist
das mein Skin das ist mein Skin direkt
sehen von zehn Scheiße mal One Direction
da vorne also ein Mod von mir hat auch
noch mal jetzt immer geschickt alter das
ist einfach der Teppich den ich auch
habe Mona junge läuft bei dir der
grelles Licht ich würde es nur gedimmt
lassen auf jeden Fall auch ein Bild am
Start sehr sehr schön was ist das the
weekend ist clean auf jeden Fall es ist
eigentlich schön Plattenspieler the
weekend Platten the weekend
Richtung Stil wählen außer the weekend
bei der ist immer Wochenende Alter Mona
kommt auf jeden Fall auch noch mit rein
hier auch sehr sehr schön
zum Abschluss würde ich sagen nehmen wir
noch mal das Zimmer hier was haltet ihr
von sowas so
no joke sehen alle Zimmer aus in so
zdf-serien von so Kindern dann gehen die
so rein ins Zimmer und dann ist es
überall Deko und überall steht irgendwie
was zu chaotisch im Leben ist es glaube
ich wirklich ein bisschen zu chaotisch
hier sind auch sehr viele Pflanzen ist
das dieses Buch was man aufmacht von
Harry Potter und Platten die ganzen
Seiten da drin rum zu chaotisch ne ja
lass mal raus ihr dürft jetzt
entscheiden wer gewonnen hat das hier
ist das blaue Zimmer wir haben ein
Gaming Setup mit einer Leiter nach oben
die man wahrscheinlich ein und
ausklappen kann so wie ich das hier
beurteilen kann dann kann man hier oben
entspannt schlafen der schöne Zimmer
sehr warm sehr gut geschnitten aber sie
liegt mit dem Rücken zur Tür
wahrscheinlich
sehr ordentlich sehr so aus wie so ein
wie geht's immer ja Abstimmung endet in
drei zwei
eins und gewonnen hat blau meine Damen
und Herren 49% hat blau bekommen 41% hat
Mona bekommen die Katze hat nur 9%
bekommen
hast nix ja Leute danke euch für die
ganzen Zimmer Einsendungen hat mir auf
jeden Fall sehr viel Spaß gemacht darauf
mal wieder zu reagieren
[Musik]